Sí buenas tardes Santiago hay que decir
que este proyecto y otro que será
presentado el lunes o que iba a ser
presentado el lunes por las fuerzas que
son es que están con el gobierno de
Manuel macronzos alianza de partidos de
la mayoría presidencial tenían nada que
ver y tienen son una reacción a lo que
ocurrió en Estados Unidos por eso que
ambos partidos ambos bloques quisieron
inscribir este derecho en la
Constitución para que nadie pueda
eliminar las leyes un derecho que se
adquirió en 1975 gracias a Simón y Hoy
fue un día muy complicado Pues esta era
la propuesta de la Francia insumisa del
partido de izquierda que tenía muchas
enmiendas unas 200 de parte del partido
de los republicanos de derecha y de la
extrema derecha porque incluía una
palabra la contracepción el derecho
también a la contracepción Y eso no
gustaba sobre todo a los diputados
conservadores y también a los de la
mayoría presidencial por lo que
finalmente Después de cinco horas de
debate llegaron a un acuerdo sacaron esa
palabra y básicamente este proyecto de
la izquierda ha sido aprobado por lo
tanto el día lunes ya no habrá la
discusión de ese segundo proyecto pero
queda otro paso más importante ahora y
es el senado donde la mayoría justamente
es de la derecha y de los partidos del
centro que son muy conservadores y no
está claro que este proyecto vaya a ser
aprobado ya el 19 de octubre se presentó
otro proyecto que era de todos los
partidos de multipartidista Y fue
rechazado por el senado
como bien decías la tendrá difícil no en
el senado pero supongamos un hipotético
escenario en el cual el proyecto es
aprobado no por este senado de mayoría
conservador como decías que seguiría
entonces
si Efectivamente es muy hipotético pero
supongamos que pasa que hay un acuerdo
justamente entre las fuerzas políticas
en ese senado más conservador francés
pues como es una ley constitucional que
modifica la Constitución debe ser
sometida un referéndum y tampoco es algo
simple Aunque un 80% más de un 80% de
los franceses dicen estar de acuerdo con
el derecho al aborto y con que este se
inscrito en la Constitución no es un de
un debate fácil en la sociedad francesa